good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is be authentic over to you
Oprah Winfrey I think that success is a
process and I believe that my first
Easter speech in Kosciusko Baptist
Church at the age of three and a half
was was the beginning and that every
other speech every other book I read
every other time I spoke in public was
was a building block so that by the time
I first sat down to audition in front of
a television camera and somebody says
read this what allows me to read it so
comfortably and be so at ease with
myself at that time for the fact that
I've been doing in a while if I've never
read a book like never spoken in public
before I would have been traumatized by
it so the fact that we went on the air
with The Oprah Winfrey Show in 1986
nationally and people say oh but you see
how you're so comfortable in front of
camera you can be yourself well it's
because I've been being myself since I
was 19 and I would not have I would not
have been able to be as comfortable with
myself had I not made mistakes on the
air and been allowed to make mistakes on
the air and understand that it doesn't
matter you know I there's no such thing
to me as an embarrassing moment no such
thing if I tripped and fell if my bra
strap showed if my flip fell off if I
fell flat on my face there's no such
thing as an embarrassing moment because
I know that there is not a moment that I
could possibly experience on the air
that somebody else hasn't already
experienced so when it happens you say
oh let slip fell off and it's no big
deal I mean like I was on TV the other
day in places all over you have a run
have you not seen a run before in your
life well
I get them to let me tell you so I mean
I can't be embarrassed I can't be
embarrassed now when I first started out
that was not true because I was under
think I was pretending to be somebody I
was not I was pretending to be Barbara
Walters so I go to a news conference and
I was more interested in how I phrased
the question and how eloquent the
question sounded as opposed to listening
to the answer I saw what which always
happens when you're interested in
impressing people instead of doing what
you're supposed to be doing and it took
me a while it took me messing up on the
air on during a live newscast I was
doing a list of foreign countries I
there was all these foreign names and
then Canada was thrown in and I call
Canada Canada and I got so tickled that
I called Kenna I thought that wasn't
Kannada that was Camelot excuse me that
was some kind of above that wasn't
Kannada up with Canada and then I
started laughing well it was it was it
became a mutt became the first real
moment I ever had and the news director
later said to me well if you do that
then you should just keep going you
shouldn't correct yourself and let
people know all right now well who's
ever heard our kannada so that was for
me the beginning of realizing that oh
you can laugh at yourself and you can
make a mistake and it's not the end of
the world you don't have to be perfect
and biggest lesson for me for television
because then it didn't matter didn't
matter osiris-rex showing not being
afraid to make mistakes is one of the
hardest things to learn how to do and
probably one of the most useful and
important things that you can learn not
just as an entrepreneur as a human being
you know when I first started doing
YouTube I was terrified of making a
mistake I was terrified of what you guys
would think I was terrified of putting
out an imperfect product I was trying to
memorize lines and in my first videos
they were really they were really fake
it was a fake version of me because I
was trying to get the exact words right
everyone knows Walt Disney
moving theme park and cast of characters
but most people don't know is when you
first started out he had no money he had
to live in his office because he
couldn't afford rent for an apartment
and he survived on a diet of cold beans
because we couldn't afford food I would
be sitting down I'd be you know looking
up trying to memorize my lines and when
I realized with much more practice with
that it doesn't matter the exact words
that I use it's more than feeling its
mother genuineness and it's taking me a
lot of times it gets to that right I've
made 5,000 videos now and I've been
working on working on and working on it
and I wish there were a lot more actual
genuine moments too and I wish there
were more mistakes I don't really make a
ton of bloopers when I'm making these
videos my team was always worried about
walking through shots and I'm actually
excited I think we got one where Alex
was picking up a table of moving in that
like I'm cheering them on pump tup that
he's in the shot that we made a kind of
blooper a mistake did we get outs in
there yeah nice nice I love it I love it
even last month when my audio didn't
work properly you guys gave me a ton a
ton it's probably the most negative
comments in the history of our channel
every video we put up we got comments
about the echo and am I in a cave and
people want to fly here to buy me a mic
and some of them were funny and some of
them were just super hate and negative
and I kept the videos up because I make
mistakes right because I make mistakes
my teammate makes mistakes we're still
human and I wanted to use that as look
here's the channel that has eight
hundred thousand subscribers and we're
still making mistakes and we're still
trying to figure things out and that's
authentic for me and so I think the
biggest thing is one just realizing have
any awareness to understand that you are
holding yourself back because of a fear
of judgement fear of not being yourself
fear what people might think about you
most of the time we do things that are
so just subconscious and we don't take
action on it recognising that here's a
moment right now where you are afraid to
do something because how somebody might
judge you and then doing something about
it and then taking action against it and
then slowly building up that muscle so
that the next time it happens you're
able to expand your comfort zone a
little bit more and just being able to
recognize that in your head you have
this rationale you rationalize you cope
with all the reasons why you shouldn't
be doing something but really it's just
that you're afraid if you can get to the
deeper cause of I'm just afraid that's
okay I'm going to push through this and
expand my comfort zone and get stronger
and stronger each time have none
awareness and then doing something about
it will help you become more authentic
and it doesn't just help you in business
people want to deal with people people
don't understand your story people want
to feel like they connect to you people
connect to me more now than they did
when I first started and I have the same
message that I did when I started it's
just the way I deliver it it's much more
authentic and so if you want to reach
people and have them take action and
grow your business authenticity is
really important you hear that message
over and over again on the channel but
also just helps you as a human being to
know that you can be yourself be
comfortable in your own skin not be
constantly worried when you're out at
parties or in social events of how
people might be seeing you and judging
you if you're if that's the world you
live in when you're constantly afraid of
how people are seeing you then you're
never actually going to be yourself and
that is not a happy place to be and so
that awareness to understand when you're
holding yourself back and then to
actually do something about it
take the action even though you're
afraid do that consistently and you'll
see a significant growth not just in
your personal life but also in your
business so the question today is I'm
curious what is the thing that you have
the hardest time being authentic about
the thing of the hardest time being your
true self about leave it down in the
comments below really curious to find
out and if you leave a comment within
the first couple hours of this video
going live you have a chance to win one
of two daily prizes I also want to give
a quick shredder - Penelope Stansfield
from green frogs dot fr Penelope thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word really really means a
lot to me and I hope you join the read
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events better
expresso TV go
adopt the mode of authentic being and
that is something like refusing to
participate in the lie in deception in
the lie to orient your speech as much as
you can towards the truth and to take
responsibility for your own life and
perhaps also for the lives of other
people and there's something about that
that's meaningful and responsible and
Noble but also serves to mitigate the
very suffering that produces say the
nihilism or the flee into the arms of
Plenty or or the or the escape into the
arms of totalitarians to begin with you
need something to shelter you against
your own vulnerability you know you're
watching a movie and you hear a lion and
it feels like oh they thought that was
gonna be a line in the trailer like you
just know that on the set someone's like
that's a trailer mode like it doesn't
because it doesn't feel real necessarily
in life but it just feels like a great
sound by it's a great thing that there's
a visual equivalent of that and you got
to be really careful because sometimes
I'll think this is like one of those
moments and then you end up doing it and
the truth is it ends up feeling posed it
just doesn't feel authentic I try for
those sometimes they never seem to work
I think that the key for any of this
stuff and you know whether we've
accomplished it or not is up to the
audience but I think that the key to any
movie working certainly a movie called
Star Trek which you know could you know
be seen as campy is finding authenticity
and and it's whether it's in a little
nuance a little moment a character
exchange a look a glance or a huge plot
point there's something for me that is
if I don't really understand what's
going on if I can't really get into
under the skin of these characters none
of the spectacles of the matter and I
give it my all I mean I I practice every
day and I try and stay authentic and
uncompromising we don't play any you
know crowd-pleasing stuff we don't you
know get out there and play when the
saints go marching in and you know will
we play blues hymns ragtime whorehouse
music
stuff that was authentically New Orleans
and we play it in the New Orleans style
as best we can and so I don't feel that
I'm a sellout I'm doing the best I can